.
>> REPORTER: ABSOLUTE EUPHORIA
HERE AT THE MOMENT.
COMMUNICATED BY THE, CAMERA BY
SATELLITE.
IT'S A BIT OF A CHAOTIC MASS.
NO PHONE SIGNAL HERE.
THE RUSSIANS HAVE TAKEN ALL OF
THAT, DOWN JUST ROARED THE
ELECTRICITY, THE WATER, THE GAS,
EVERYTHING HERE.
EVERYONE HERE IS OUT
CELEBRATING IN THIS WAY HERE.
PEOPLE AROUND THE UKRAINIAN
LIKE, THEY'RE HUGGING THE
SOLDIERS.
THEY COME OUT TO SEE HOW IT IS
TO HAVE FREEDOM.
I'M JOINED HERE BY THESE TWO
WOMEN AND WE'RE GOING TO HAVE A
QUICK CONVERSATION.
TELL US ABOUT THE LAST EIGHT
MONTHS UNDER RUSSIAN
OCCUPATION.
>> IT WAS REALLY HARD TIME FOR
EVERYONE.
EVERY UKRAINIAN FAMILY WAITED
FOR OUR SOLDIERS, FOR OUR ARMY.
>> REPORTER: HOW DOES IT FEEL
NOW TODAY, TO SEE THEM?
>> IT'S A AMAZING.
WONDERFUL.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
SUPPORTING US.
WE FEEL VERY DEEP YOUR SUPPORT..
CAN I HELP YOU?
>> REPORTER: SURE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
[APPLAUSE]
>> REPORTER: CAN WE TALK?
>> YES, SURE.
>> REPORTER: CAN'T TELL US YOUR
EXPERIENCE OF THE LAST MONTHS?
>> WE WERE WAITING SO LONG.
BUT WE WERE SURE THAT THIS DAY
WILL COME AND WILL CELEBRATE
TOGETHER WITH OUR PEOPLE HERE
AND EVERYWHERE IN THE WORLD.
THANKS FOR ALL THOSE WHO
SUPPORTED US AND HELPS US.
BUT THIS DAY, WE'RE SO HAPPY TO
BE HERE.
WE'RE SO HAPPY WITH OUR PEOPLE,
JUST CELEBRATE THIS DAY.
THIS IS SOMETHING AMAZING, BUT
IT WAS HARD, BUT WE ALWAYS KNEW
THAT THIS DAY WILL COME.
>> REPORTER: I THINK WHAT
EVERYONE WANTS TO KNOW NOW WHO
IS OUTSIDE OF HERE, WHAT IS THE
SITUATION HERE NOW?
PLEASE TELL US ABOUT THAT.
>> SITUATION IS VERY TERRIBLE.
NO ELECTRICITY, NO POWER.
CONNECTION.
THIS IS VERY IMPORTANT FOR
PEOPLE.
PEOPLE ARE LOST.
>> REPORTER: NO INTERNET
CONNECTION.
>> NO INTERNET CONNECTION,
RIGHT.
NO WATER.
BUT IT IS OKAY.
WE CAN WAIT.
WE CAN.
WAIT MORE IMPORTANT IS THAT
UKRAINE IS HERE.
WE CAN CALL OUR FAMILIES,
RELATIVES, FRIENDS.
WE WANT TO SAY WE ARE TOGETHER.
>> REPORTER: I THINK A LOT OF
PEOPLE WERE WORRIED, THE
GOVERNMENT WAS WORRIED, IF THE
RUSSIAN SOLDIERS WITH STAY
BEHIND, IF THERE WOULD BE A
BATTLE HERE.
DO YOU FEEL THE CITY IS SAFE
NOW?
>> YES.
CITY IS SAFE.
>> REPORTER: TELL US HOW IT WAS
BECAUSE WE HAVEN'T HAD GOOD
INFORMATION.
WHAT WAS THE SITUATION LIKE
LIVING WITH RUSSIAN SOLDIERS?
>> THE PEOPLE YOU CAN SEE HERE
NOW, I THINK MANY OF THEM WERE
HIDING.
THEY'RE HIDING THE UKRAINIAN
PLAYED SOMEWHERE IN THE CORNER
WE WERE TERRIFIED BY RUSSIAN
ARMY.
WE WERE TERRIFIED BY SOLDIERS
THAT CAN COME ANY MOMENT IN OUR
HOUSE AND HOME.
JUST OPEN THE DOOR LIKE THEY'RE
LIVING HERE AND STEAL, KIDNAP,
TORTURE.
AND THIS WAS VERY TERRIBLE.
I HAVE GOOSE POND'S NOW WHEN
I'M TALKING.
BUT WE DID THAT.
WE WAIT.
WE HAVE FREEDOM NOW.
>> REPORTER: WHAT NOW?
WHAT YOUR HOPES NOW?
NOW YOU HAVE LIBERATION AND
FREEDOM.
WHAT ARE YOUR HOPES?
>> WE FEEL FREE.
WE'RE NOT SLAVES.
WE ARE UKRAINIANS.
WE ARE PROUD OF IT.
>> YES, I AGREE.
I AGREE.
>> REPORTER: THANK YOU BOTH
VERY MUCH INDEED.
>> THANK YOU.
>> FREEDOM FOR UKRAINE.
>> REPORTER: A TELL YOU A
LITTLE BIT ABOUT OUR JOURNEY
DOWN HERE BECAUSE IT WAS QUITE
THE JOURNEY, DRIVING THROUGH
VAST AREAS OF COUNTRYSIDE,
GOING THROUGH.
THERE ARE MINES ON THE ROAD.
THEY WERE BLOWN BRIDGES ON THE
ROAD TO GET HERE.
THE RUSSIANS REALLY MADE IT
HARD FOR UKRAINIAN FORCES TO
ADVANCE DOWN HERE AND LIBERATE
KHERSON.
THAT'S SAD, THE COUNTRYSIDE IS
ALMOST ENTIRELY DESERTED.
VERY FEW VEHICLES ON THE ROAD
AND THE ROADS ARE BADLY
DAMAGED.
THIS CITY TO GET THE
RESTORATION OF POWER, TO GET
INTERACTION.
EVERYONE HAS COME TO USE OUR
INTERNET CONNECTION THAT WE'RE
TALKING TO YOU ON RIGHT NOW.
TO GET THESE THINGS ESTABLISHED,
THERE'S REALLY A LOT OF DAMAGE
THIS HAPPENED.
IT'S CLEAR THAT IT'S GOING TO
TAKE A LONG TIME.
BUT THIS IS JUST A MOMENT OF
EUPHORIA HERE.
JUST A MOMENT OF CELEBRATION
WHERE PEOPLE CAN COME IN A
SQUARE, SHOW THEIR FLIGHTS,
REMEMBER, VALUE THE BEGINNING
OF THE WAR.
THIS WAS THE CITY.
BACK ONE OF THE RUSSIAN TROOPS
ROLLED IN HERE, BEGINNING OF
THE WAR, THIS WAS A CITY THAT
TRIED TO RESIST.
THEY HAD PROTESTS.
IT'S CELEBRATION.
♪ ♪ ♪
>> REPORTER: THIS IS WHAT
LIBERATION LOOKS LIKE.
THIS IS WHAT LIBERATION FEELS
LIKE.
THE PEOPLE OF THE CITY TRIED TO
RESIST THE RUSSIANS.
THE RUSSIANS SUPPRESS THEM.
THIS IS WHAT UKRAINIANS ARE
LIKE WHEN THAT SUPPRESSION
COMES OFF.
♪ ♪ ♪
[APPLAUSE]
>> REPORTER: I THINK IT MIGHT
SURPRISE MANY.
IT WOULD SURPRISE MANY OF THOSE
RUSSIAN SOLDIERS WHO WERE HERE,
TO KNOW THAT THESE PASSIONS,
THESE FEELINGS, WE'RE JUST
BENEATH THE SURFACE.
THIS WAS A CITY WHERE PEOPLE
WERE TAKEN AWAY.
WHERE THEY WERE TORTURED.
THEY WOULD DISAPPEAR.
THIS IS THE SPIRIT.
THIS IS THE SPEAR WHEN THE
RUSSIANS ARE GONE AND THEY CAN
BE THEMSELVES.
IT IS QUITE REMARKABLE TO
WITNESS.
THIS WAS WHERE PEOPLE BEGAN
WHEN THE RUSSIANS INVADED
TRYING TO RESIST THEM,
EVENTUALLY B